welcome back to the David Pacman show I
am Jesse dollar Moore sitting in for
David while he is away
[Laughter]
look some stories just bring me
um a chef's kiss amount of joy is is
chef's kiss a measurement that I can use
is how much joy I feel when I get to
talk about Donald Trump Jr and his
podcast
Donald Trump Jr just started a podcast I
guess titled after his book of the same
name triggered
and in it it is similar to the videos
you may or may not see on Twitter where
he gesticulates wildly and look not
being one who who lives in a glass house
and wants to throw stones you know I'm
somebody who gesticulates I'm somebody
who waves his hands around maybe more
than I should I certainly get taken to
task on it about it on YouTube but
Donald Trump Jr just has a fundamental
dis misunderstanding about how air
quotes work in some of these videos he
just sits there and and does air quotes
for several seconds in a row about
everything he says a shared desire to
keep quiet early on Biden's attorneys
and justice department investigators
both thought they had a shared
understanding about keeping the matter
quiet but they had very different
reasons
I mean seriously it could be leveraging
the fact that they have those secrets
and that Joe was irresponsible with them
to gain whatever advantage over the
United States of course of course they
had a desire to keep it quiet but the
fact that the media is quiet about it
the fact that if all the leftists don't
say anything about it that in and of
itself is actually the story
it's just bizarre and this is like maybe
the third episode of his podcast and
this mashup I believe is from
um Ron filipowski on Twitter and it
really it says a lot about what
conservatives tune into and where they
get their information and what they find
credible this is a remarkable clip this
mashup that is as all over the place as
really anything that I've witnessed in
recent memory it is it is schizophrenic
in nature to use it to colloquialize
that term watch this nuttiness
from the ex-president's son Donald Trump
Jr
credited not actually but the media
always said discredited they don't think
they constantly said they're discredited
that's the way the media does their
things because journalists actually
refuse to actually be journalists like
God forbid they do a job God forbid they
don't just rubber stamp the Democrat
talking points it's that while the
company wouldn't dare admit it publicly
they do mutate viruses branded
conspiracy theorists well like every
conspiracy theorist if you wait a couple
weeks you'll be proven right who would
possibly do that what is this like the
1980s like are we still pretending that
all of these people have our best
intentions are the highly educated and
sophisticated media class that know
better do that when elections when
everything's won by basis points margins
a couple points here and there you know
those people who aren't paying attention
that much you know what if I can get
that guy even wondering maybe it doesn't
even show up big part of I think while
we're in Ukraine I've read some really
interesting threads about like sort of
the the labs that are over there I'm not
going to talk about them I got to
research it a little bit more but like
look at why else we may be in Ukraine
and why maybe it's okay if we let other
people kind of mutate viruses and when
the Russians do it it's bioengineering
and when we do it it's checking to make
sure we're preventing Panda yeah
he's feeling really unsafe right now
really he was sort of like well you know
we do this but not really that much I
mean what's a couple of mutations right
I mean folks it takes one
[Laughter]
uh doing his own research Donald Trump
Jr there
talking about how every conspiracy
theory if you wait a couple weeks it
ends up being true
listen this is hilarious and this is
funny and it's mockable because he's a
but it is troubling because of the
fact that there's a wide swath of the
country who looks at this individual
this troubled goon
and thinks he's credible and thinks he's
smart and thinks he has it together and
thinks he has access to information that
they don't because he's the son of the
ex-guy
we're in trouble
I'd love to know what you think about
this I know David has a phone number you
can mix it up in the comments on YouTube
this is something that I would love to
get your take on once again I am Jesse
dollimore I host I doubt it podcast on
everywhere the podcasts are I host the
dollar more daily on YouTube and you can
catch me on social media on Twitter
Instagram and Tick Tock I am at
dollarmore